[Music]
[Applause]
Taylor Swift returns to the stage for
the first time since E.T exclusively
revealed her split from Joe Alwyn and it
wasn't all smooth sailing there aren't
really heavy pressures that come with
this life and you just have to try to
balance them on Thursday the singer
resumed her heiress tour in Tampa
Florida where she kicked things off with
a bit of a flub accidentally announcing
Thursday's opener as Gracie Abrams when
it was actually Gail
I can't remember a time where I didn't
know Taylor Swift
I can't believe it I feel like I'm lying
I feel like this is a dream I don't know
where I am I don't know what I'm doing
in true Taylor fashion she handled the
mishap like a boss and even promised to
get her tour mates lots of presents to
make up for it if I make mistakes and
learn lessons that's like a headline
Taylor also debuted a new dress for her
Enchanted performance sporting this
sparkling gown by Ellie Saab with flower
petal embellishments it's just
unbelievable she later rocked a new
green two-piece number for her folklore
era including a long cape I got her
dress for tonight
and for the 1989 set she sported a new
orange fringe look I would always like
to keep people on their toes as for that
epic stage dive Taylor's done night
after night well she had a bit of a
hiccup and wasn't able to do the trick
on time telling the crowd to hang on a
sec until it was safe for her to dive
head first
[Music]
these are things that made me break out
in a full body sweat and while there
were a few minor mishaps Taylor did what
Taylor does best keeping fans guessing
by singing two surprise songs for the
sold out crowd I just have a great time
with these things speak now
ah
a Daydream and treacherous from 2012's
red
[Music]
of course this all comes after ET
exclusively reported that Taylor and Joe
who famously kept their relationship
private called it quits a few weeks ago
A source told E.T at the time that the
split was amicable and it was not
dramatic the relationship had just run
its course fans have speculated that
their relationship inspired several of
Taylor's tracks like Invisible String
London boy and gorgeous
[Music]
I can't say anything to your feelings
as a songwriter there are times when you
are working harder to find the
inspiration and then there are those
random instances where all you have to
do is grab it now swifties will
use what to wait and see if Taylor pens
any songs about their split do any of
the guys ever ask you in the beginning
hey are if this doesn't work out are you
gonna write about me no they say that in
the ending they do
no they never they never go into this
and be like I really want to ask you out
okay
they say that when we're breaking up and
they're like you better not write a song
about this and I'm like oh I won't and
then I do
[Music]
foreign